what is the one element of traditional
corporate culture you erase that gets in
the way of developing stars you know
politics what you know now that you know
vaynermedia in the last five years I've
grown the company quite a bit so we're
very fortunate you know whether it's
Under Armour Pepsi or Turner you know G
with we working with the biggest brands
in the world and one thing that's
holding them all back is politics you
know the game is built where people's
vested interests are not aligned with
the organization's they're bonusing
people and they're rewarding people on a
very certain task that is completely
against investing three to five years
from now every decision is predicated
especially in big companies on ninety
day terms because you're in a Wall
Street world where every 90 days they
judge you and all the money that
everybody has humans from the CEO down
are involved in is the actual stock
price and if the stock price goes down
people get sad if you look at what Jeff
Bezos does and even Mark Zuckerberg to a
degree but not as well as Bezos in my
opinion is they completely disregard
Wall Street and they're willing to have
wild swings but then you look up every
three to five years and things are
phenomenal and and so the thing that
holds them back is the scoring system
they've created for themselves which is
there in 90 day terms and there's
nothing that makes sense to invest in
start-up culture VR like Scoville just
showed you know company's going to
invest in that because that's not 90
days away from today that's not real in
90 days that's real in two years five
years nine years and so for me a lot of
entrepreneurs and me myself I've been
successful because I mentioned earlier
it's going to probably end up being the
theme of this which is I plan on doing
business for the next 40 years so why
wouldn't I bring you value and so
corporations are stuck there being
financially rewarded in 90 day windows
which is the antithesis to investing in
where the world's going [ __ ] is deep
right but it's just the truth it's you
know four people in here and I saw
people shaking their heads and I love
that I can see you guys you know the
people that have been in it they know
this truth which is smart people may not
agree with what they're doing but
they're doing it because their money
tied up in that I have clients tell me
every day that they wish they could take
the money from a television commercial
to put into Facebook video because they
believe me but they can't because the
way it's scored inside their
organization they would be vulnerable if
they ran Facebook over television so if
the brand goes down and doesn't do well
as long as they're running TV they're
safe but if they were to take a chance
and run television it run Facebook and
the business went down even if it had
nothing to do with the Facebook or TV
part they would be vulnerable to lose
their job and I don't blame them they
have mortgages they have kids to support
they have their lives so they're not
being put in a position to take risks
whereas in my life entrepreneurial and
everything on my shoulders everything on
me I'm only being rewarded to take risk
so as was the tipping point for dollars
to quit getting pissed away in
television death you know when these
companies die guys big companies die
there's a lot of people to screw that
remember of Sears being the number one
retailer in America there's a lot of
people in this room that remember tons
of things being number one and are no
longer number one back to tech we all
remember Yahoo being number one or
Microsoft being number one or you know
IBM like this is what happens
big companies go out of business and
then a new regime comes and they win
because they took advantage of the
arbitrage of marketing or innovation
that was underpriced while the incumbent
was spending money on overpriced
activities for infrastructure and so
this is just the way capitalism has
always been like you know I always laugh
when people think I say I mean I'm not
saying anything interesting I'm just you
know I may say it interesting with a
little bit of flair and a little bit of
Jersey and a little bit of cursing but
if you break down what I talk about it's
super tried-and-true I'm just you know
it's just super trying true when I
predicted three years ago that everybody
would use snapchat and everyone's like
no way that was just me doing the same
thing I did with Facebook eight years
earlier right which was when there's
enough people of us of enough people if
there's enough people enough thirteen to
eighteen year olds using the same thing
if a platform ever wins an entire
generation it will drag everybody else
down into it and so Twitter never did
that right you know other
forms over to that but snapchat did two
and a half three years ago every single
14 to 18 year old was on it which meant
it was just a matter of time so I think
I get a lot of credit for common sense
which I'll gladly take and keep giving
it to me
but I don't think it's all that
complicated sometimes I think what I do
well and what allows me to sit here and
have people want to take pictures and be
nice to me is the one difference I think
I have from a lot of people in this room
is I'm not romantic about how I make my
money and let me be very clear about
this
i won email marketing in 1997 for Wine
Library I didn't want email to get
spammed out and not be as effective it's
what made me all my money but in 1999
and 2001 and 2003 when all these other
people started doing email marketing and
I saw the conversion rates coming down
and I saw the web 2.0 coming up I was
okay to kill myself I and my own
business models because that's much more
interesting than having somebody else do
it for you right I is a lot of you know
really did well on Twitter that was my
coming-out party I had a million
followers on it I wasn't excited about
what I saw in 2011 and 12 that it was
starting to lose its attention that when
I would tweet less people would convert
into just the awareness even if or sale
or whatever I was up to so I started
investing in you know other platforms
like Instagram and paying attention to
snapchat it I mean a lot of you prop in
the tech space you know this I was
really at the height of Twitter right I
had it that wasn't fun for me but I was
willing to put myself out of business
and spend more time on other platforms
because I saw it coming
I think the biggest mistake people do is
they try to hold on to something that
doesn't exist anymore and that has been
a very big factor in my career that's a
transition
to a question Robin Hahnel Data
Solutions technology changes so much
there's always a learning curve how do
you sort of self Scout stuff teach
yourself to be ahead of that curve by
doing it it's you know meaning I just do
it like you know like we know that
pokemons go is happening right we know
it's happening right now you could say
it's a fad or it's stupid or who cares I
need to understand it not because I care
if pokemons go we'll be here in three
years but because this is the coming-out
party for AR right and like a million
apps are being developed right now
literally all of Silicon Valley is
sitting in boardrooms right now creating
there AR app and we're all going to shop
and go to football games and do all
sorts of stuff through that environment
and so you have to use it the reason I
did well on vine and snapchat was
because of Socialcam how many nerds
remember Socialcam raise your hands good
six of us so
Socialcam was an app that was hot for
like 47 seconds it was Vig by the
Facebook newsfeed they got millions of
users I jumped on it I used it a bunch
and then it died it died the way that
Plurk died it died the way that vine in
some ways has you know things come and
go but I'm not crippled by putting in
the work because that understanding is
then applied on something else there's
people in here that are like I'm never
gonna do anything with pokemons go
that's fine but you're going to do
something with AR and so you need to use
it it's like trying to run a marathon
without prepping for it you're going to
lose and a lot of you are losing
opportunity and success because you're
not anticipating what the next chess
move is so even though I didn't grow up
in the era of Pokemon and I'm not as
emotional about those characters I mean
I know Pikachu that's where it ends but
and my brother grew up with it he loves
and he's using it I don't care about the
entertainment value I care about
understanding the consumer and human
behavior around it the startup ever
having to maintain positivity and a
healthy culture through the different
stages of growth especially in its
fast-paced graph so Vayner went from 30
to 650 people in four years and from one
to five offices including London and you
know the way I've kept culture is
dictatorship
you know it's just the thing that I care
about the most and so you know here's
how you keep culture when Kristen in the
office is upset about something and I'm
on my way from Connecticut into New York
to do a new business pitch potentially
worth five million dollars and I detour
and skip that pitch to go and talk out
with her that issue that's how you
maintain culture guys life's very simple
there's there's the things you wish you
were doing there's the things you're
saying that you're doing and then
there's the things that you actually do
the way you maintain culture is the same
answer as the question prior to this you
do it
in your actions I don't meet with every
single employee that works for me for
ten minutes three months in to check the
box and seem like a personal CEO I do it
because in those 10 minutes I want to
create some sort of connection that
makes them feel comfortable to say hi to
me in the elevator or to like come with
a problem to me I do it because I ask
them where their hometown is so I can
make a joke about the Cleveland Indians
in the elevator to show them that I was
paying attention I do it because I want
to know if they are have siblings how
they roll what interests are they in
because if I want to surprise and
delight them because they're crushing it
that I can get them Coachella tickets
right I do it because purpose and so I
maintain culture very simply
dictatorship my actions and the number
one and two other options are
meritocracy letting talent speak for
itself and then finally firing the most
talented people if they're not willing
to care about their teammates more than
them thinking they're fancy and you know
my ego is so big that I don't think I
need anybody that works for my company
and so thus they're all expendable if
they're not willing to treat each other
with respect and love
I think one of the reasons they respect
you following is leaders because you are
a practitioner you're yeah I I stand in
front of those 500 or so 25 year olds
and I'm like I'm the best at social
media in this office right and I mean it
I and and that's because I use it more
than they do I mean they're using it to
hook up I'm trying to sell [ __ ] and I
mean that I think what's interesting
about that is where I got really lucky
with vaynermedia I don't know how you
feel about your agency but what happened
for me is I don't care about the
creative it's subjective I don't care
about the awards I don't want to can
Lyon I want to sell stuff and at some
level somewhere within the organization
eventually somebody cares about that too
you know we don't win business sometimes
because they care about their job and
they don't wanna do social over TV
respect we you know some people are
worried that I'm too busy doing other
things in that respect you can think
anything but at the end of the day again
back to the other two things results are
results and results we take over sour
patch kids as a client and they become
the fastest-growing candy in the
category that's real there's no debating
whether you don't like that I cursed
along the way or that we did some weird
new things Mazel Tov but the fact that
matter is the results or results and so
that's what I live on I know what our
intent is we're not worried about our
profit margin mainly because we think
we're gonna get it all in the end of the
day you know making 8 percent margin on
400 millions a hell of a lot more
interesting than making 20% on 30
million and so I'm playing the long game
I always have it's why a lot of you have
good relationships with me I see you at
different places I know who you are I
care I interact with you like life is
simple like the truth wins you may be
confused because times are tough and the
media and there's always issues in this
country and we got flaws and all that
stuff you're more than welcome to look
at the pessimistic aspects of society in
life I choose to in my 8090 years
hopefully on earth to understand that I
got to be a human being which if you
want to talk about big data and math the
rarity of actually becoming a person is
insane and just way too many people
don't understand that
and appreciate it and I do and so I'm
playing the long game on all this stuff
we're pretty good pretty much super
lucky and you live in America you could
have been a rhinoceros or like a tree
that [ __ ] tree next question that's
another one successfully on CNBC's
follow the leader says nobody out works
I really believe that on YouTube without
exhausting or you know killing all those
arounds that's a great question
over communicating you know I mean it
just comes down to communication I have
to talk with Lizzy a lot you know the
kids are getting older and that I do
think yeah I do think this would be the
I'm getting into the end of the new year
of like 17 and 18 hour days because my
children are now seven and four and
there's just more stuff that comes along
with that and so I think that's fine and
that's great you know but it comes down
to communication you know I think people
talk about work-life balance a lot of
ever since I started doing dailyvee
which is my video blog daily kind of
vlog thing and and snapchat I think a
lot of you that have followed me for
several years have started really
realizing I wasn't joking that I was
working this much I think prior when I
would talk about hustle I think people
like yeah he works hard but like when
you get to see that it's fully
documented and there's no no cheating
and I'm working 7:00 a.m. to midnight
every single day every single day every
single minute it becomes intimidating
it's my natural you know just so like
some of you are very smart and some of
you are very pretty and some of you are
very funny like it's my natural state to
hustle that hard not being born in this
country coming up with nothing you know
feeling guilty that you have certain
talents there's a million reasons that
it drives me but what I love about this
question is it's not how do I do it it's
how do I keep the people around me in a
healthy place it's a super intense thing
man
I think I never judge anybody's
work-life balance you know as a matter
of fact here's a good opportunity for me
I always want to clear this up I don't
think you should work 15 hours a day I
think if you're complete here's my punch
line if you're complaining about your
life
you need to look at what you're doing so
for example I have friends that are
making hundreds of millions of dollars
in their careers tens of millions of
dollars a year and they're complaining
that they are not spending time with
their family then spend time with your
family DIC and then I have and that I
have people emailing me every day
complaining that their business is not
taking off and I go do one quick Twitter
search and there's six pm tweet is
hitting the links with my buddies like
you know you're not going to win and
build a big business if you're watching
Game of Thrones and playing Pokemon go
all day like it's just that nobody's won
on just talent hard work is part of the
equation so I don't judge anybody I
think I get judged because I put myself
out there and then I deserve to be
judged and when people hit me up and say
you're gonna regret this you're gonna
regret this and I get that I get those
emails I reply all the time like you
don't know me like I respect why you're
saying that because I don't you know one
thing that something that really follow
me know is my wife and I've decided not
to share our family life on social so
unlike a lot of my tech friends who use
the Q pictures of their kids to get more
likes on their social media I'm not
interested in doing that with my
children I'm gonna let them decide Misha
is already I think she's gonna have a
youtube show in a week so it seems like
she wants to do that great but I don't
want to do that and so it feels even
more extreme right you know and I always
ask people that really call me out on it
I'm like if you're paying attention to
me so much why haven't you noticed that
I put out zero snapchat content over the
weekends right like like why don't you
really pay attention what do you think
I'm doing between 6:00 p.m. and 9:00
p.m. when you see nothing like like I'm
documenting every moment aa minute so
you know I'm spending it I'm spending
far less family time than most but
there's a whole nother aspect of family
time I have a lot of friends from high
school that like to critique me because
it's the yin and yang of like yeah
you're making money but um I'm a family
man and I say to them I'm like cool but
I know you and you come home at 6
o'clock at night and you go to your man
cave and drink six Budweiser's and go to
sleep so [ __ ] you
so so you know just cuz you're in the
same house as your children doesn't mean
your parenting yeah so just order for a
while you're talking about hustling til
6:00 p.m. going on for three hours and
getting back after if you'd acted that
yeah so this September and honestly it
doesn't feel good to me right now I
don't feel like I'm ready for it but I'm
really trying to sell myself which is
why I'm saying it publicly to come home
during the weekday I'm I'm such a
momentum guy you know like I'm so
momentum oriented so the thought of
coming home at 6:00 in the middle of my
day and that's my middle day and spend
an hour with the kids and then kind of
read like switch the brain to be in kids
mode when it is school you know what's
going on in the world and then reset
back to being back and trying to like
stab people in the face and when is hard
but I'm gonna have to pull it off I'm
very it's important to me you know I'm
getting a lot of time with my kids on
the weekends and we're taking a lot of
vacation time now I'm really in a much
better place than it was several years
ago but I'm feeling uncomfortable with
the idea of how consistently I can go
four or five days in a row being in New
York seeing them zero it just doesn't
feel as right as it did 18 months ago 12
months ago so I'm just you know I'm a
smoke than fire guy right like I'm just
what I'm doing right now is I'm selling
myself more than telling you a story of
like this is something I want to do and
some just beating on my own brain to get
there it goes back to what you said to
switch it you're switching your mother
business man
sometimes if you're at the house from 6
to 9 but you're not present you know
you're still in this is happening all
day like like like you know I think what
you're sensing and I'm sure a lot of you
don't deeply know me like I'm very
comfortable in my own skin I'm
comfortable with my politically correct
shortcomings because it's my life and my
kid's life and my wife's life like I
know what's happening inside our four
walls so I just wish more people would
feel comfortable I think if you're happy
so much more happens so I know a lot of
people this one this one woman's a CEO
of a company I invested and she's
amazing she feels the need to check the
box to they world to her mother to her
friends that she comes home and spends
more time with her family but every
minute she's in that house I'm getting
emails from her on questions about the
business she's not there and I told her
I was like you need to and she's not
perfectly happy because of it because
she doesn't want to be home she wants to
be running her business she loves her
family she's just on fire and she wants
it and so like I just don't think people
understand how long-term life is you
know like there's a lot of different
ways to do it everybody has their own
way you're looking at a kid not anymore
but you're looking at a guy whose dad I
didn't see from the ages of seven until
fourteen ever and we were parents were
together it's just that he left before I
woke up and he came home after I went to
sleep and I loved my dad more than
breathing I mean my dad have it awesome
I think we've gotten into a very
hardcore politically correct zone where
for some reason between social media and
just the topics of the day everybody's
wants to impose their point of view of
the world on other people and I think
that's stupid so so on the work-life
balance thing I've got my thing it's
what feels right I think everybody in
here has to keep themselves happy first
then you can make other people happy and
and it evolves and it changes I mean I'm
not convinced that I might not just one
year wake up and just check out for a
year just cuz I might just I don't know
it's it's funny to me that it runs
through my head sometimes maybe in
between businesses if something
happens I don't know I don't know but
right now I can tell you like hustling
producing for my family producing for
myself producing for my employees of my
team and producing content for you guys
it I'm as happy as it gets awesome let's
talk about earning ham for a second okay
this question comes from 100 executive
vice president attendings what is the
one thing that we can do here in
Birmingham as a community to grow the
technology community what local entities
need to be involved what can we do to
make it successful you need a win
and what I mean by a win I mean not win
you need a win and so I think a lot of
communities and I've spent a lot of time
obviously we opened an office in
Chattanooga Tennessee
I helped kick off big Omaha there's a
cancelled conference that I had
committed to and it's gone on to become
a big deal I got an email from a kid
yesterday in Oklahoma City because I
went there in 2009 that a bunch of the
leaders in the market said holy crap
wait a minute we all start our business
after that garyvee talk so bringing
Scoble and things that nature this I
mean this is unbelievably important
right like so many more people are
asking me questions about you guys today
right now on social why are you there
what's going on but you don't need to
bring anybody me Scoble anything the
real win for any community is you need
to support each other and get a win a
company coming from this town that makes
a global or at least a national impact
on the scene is what it takes to take a
city and put it on the map that's just
the truth and so you know look LA was a
it's not it's not that you need a big
exit I don't want to play the VC game
you don't need a big round you don't
need to bring in a big impact right like
need a big impact like guys snapshot
coming out of LA has changed la tech and
la is a big city right but these things
matter
Go Daddy in Arizona these things matter
even de Walla you know a lot of these
companies start in places well you need
to figure out what the city needs to
figure out is I'm positive
and I'm and you guys know me I'm not
pandering to you I don't give a [ __ ] how
you feel about me I'm positive that
something amazing will come out of here
my concern is as soon as it starts
happening you're going to move to San
Francisco and that's what happens
Facebook was started in Boston Pinterest
was started in Pennsylvania so the key
is not only to Wester the community to
help each other tech wise marketing wise
to have a win but then what can you guys
do from a city and state level to make
that person or that team want to ground
themselves here for the long haul and
everybody that comes from a smaller town
than a top-five City always feels like
they have to go to one of those cities
to make it because of the tech talent or
the venture capital I believe that to
not be true anymore because of the
infrastructure around the internet
marketing world today so that's what
that's the truth you can do a lot of
events you can do a lot of marketing but
what you need is a win and I think if
you get really back to the opening line
here today 5149 giving more to others if
you've got a business in this community
that is not a direct competitor of your
business and you have more marketing
chops or you have more technical chops
cross pollinating and helping each other
is exactly what small towns can do
better than big towns and I highly
recommend that southern hospitality that
is deeply rooted in your DNA to begin
with that you figure out how to use that
in a business environment as well
because the impact of one of those
people popping and winning will have a
bigger ROI on your business as a halo
effect than if you do it separately I
know it's cool being here it's true
thanks for the claps but what's even
more interesting is I think it's you
know back to stereotypes I think it's
more natural in you I can tell you right
now there's not a lot of people from
Jersey they're just gonna hook it up you
know instead of like I do think that you
should take it I think everybody should
bet on their strengths and I think that
sense of community that you guys have is
very real and you should take full
advantage of it and I think the
entrepreneurs in the audience get into
the sharp elbows entrepreneur DNA and
leave a little bit of that DNA of
southern hospitality on the side and
actually think they should go completely
the other way yeah I mean
because that is the culture entre
percent and technology makes it to where
you can level playing field from cuz
it's level you know well I think I think
I think there's a lot of things I think
it's just momentum you know again being
somebody who's kicked off and been at
the inaugural conference of a lot of
small cities by comparison to New York
San Francisco it's stunning what's
something just like this it's
unbelievable I'm so proud to be here
I definitely think with all the stories
I get to tell my children and
grandchildren one day the fact that
during this 20-year era that I went and
used my micro Fame within the community
to go to places that were not New York
MLA in San Francisco and in any small
part because looking I'm just flying
through its you guys do you guys that
are actually making it happen but to
even be point zero zero zero one of the
narrative of being at the first
conference bending changing my schedules
doing it for less all those things it
feels nice and I'm proud of that
agency drive idiot Drive okay this
question is from Alex Kistler what are a
few ways that you make sure meetings are
quick efficient lively and its clients
internally employees and clients well if
I'm in them they're all that so that's
easy after that you just hope I the
truth is I don't I hope through osmosis
and people seeing how I want them like I
have three minute meetings with people
you know like like I think the number
one flaw in client services is you
booked a 30-minute meeting it's actually
eight minutes of work but since your
google calendar says it's thirty you
just are a human and you waste 22
minutes so I'm big on four minutes seven
minute 11 minute meetings we've AJ is
the best at this he like tried to
mandate it you know and like cut things
you know I think that I try to inspire
it through my own actions but I'm very
aware of human tendencies and
shortcomings and it just you try to
bring it up ever so often but it's a
very difficult challenge I think I think
most humans are are just not smart with
their time management next question for
Jacob Kirschenbaum
what has caused the rise of my streaming
media while the market has shifted to
delay consumption like Netflix ooh
they're just too micro kind of trends
they both work like you know I always
say to people like I really believe that
you will watch a five and a half hour
movie like I think they've how many
people here if the next star wars is
five and a half hours would be thrilled
to go watch it raise your hands
that's insane
five and a half hours nerds I run there
opening night midnight to 5:00 in the
morning and go to work in you know so I
think great content can make somebody
watch for five and F hours I also know
there's a ton of people in here that
stopped watching a six-second vine after
three seconds the length of your content
is not the variable of its quality and
so we're going to always want to watch
to our movies in one hour TV shows but
we also want to watch live streaming so
they're just two different macro trends
I don't think they're conflicting I
think one thing we have to recognize is
we only have 24 hours in a day and so if
you're allocating three six whatever
hours to entertainment they may come in
the form of Netflix they may come in the
form of live-streaming they may come in
the form of just searching Instagram or
are they it's incredible the length of
time some of you are spending in
snapchat stories like right and so I
think I think the bigger issue at hand
is that the cellphone is just so much
the remote control of our lives and I
think Stuart and later will control what
we watch on TV more and more obviously
things like augmented reality definitely
social and video and there and so what's
allowing it is just tech infrastructure
is Wi-Fi get stronger as bandwidth gets
stronger more powerful and you're not
buffering when you're watching
high-quality video from the over-the-top
networks it's time right and so you know
I some got back to Star Wars I flew from
New York to LA and watch somebody
sitting next to me watch the entire
latest Star Wars on their phone on the
flight out and why I thought that was
super important is everybody in
Hollywood it's like no big theaters and
you need the right set this guy watched
it on his phone people grossly
underestimate how much we love this
story
we love production we love a lot of
things but we love stories and stories
can come in any form I broke out on
YouTube in 2006 doing a show called Wine
Library TV and I don't know if any how
many of you ever saw a Wine Library TV
thank you
so thanks mom and so
and so as some of you might remember I
mean I look like a hostage in the Middle
East I mean there was no audio I never
wore a mic there was no lighting I mean
you know it wasn't the production value
that made it work it was the content
that was coming out of my mouth and so I
think that we get caught up some way to
so many people get caught up in the
production value and look D rocks come
into my life and clearly has taught me
there's plenty of value in that as well
but it's not an either-or and you don't
have to do both every time and so I
don't think there's anything without the
story if the story blows you don't care
about the special effects a hundred
percent 100% whether I was storytelling
the wines of New Zealand you know
Australia and Spain before anybody in
America whether I was storytelling me
and whether I'm storytelling businesses
around me that's exactly what I am and
and for me I got lucky because I think
the world went in a direction that
matched my natural skill set and
storytelling I'm comfortable and very
fast off the cuff you know raw real
authentic it just it's matched me so I'm
very grateful to be born in this era
because I wasn't moving to Hollywood in
1974 to make it right
that's you know I was 32 years old 30 I
was 30 you know I was 31 years old when
I started Wine Library TV first time I
ever made a video for the world so I
wasn't in the mindset of I'm gonna
become a personality I'm a businessman
who happens to be a little bit
charismatic so as a story to anything
you know you say danger attention yes is
that an evolution of storyteller and
just in today's market well I think a
story to be a great storyteller you
can't just be great at the story you
have to understand where it's being
distributed and how way too many
storytellers think at the context part
of storytelling you have to know where
it's being delivered what I've done very
well and when I say I day trade
attention it's back to me not being
romantic I follow you I don't get to say
that Twitter lasts forever I don't get
to say that Netflix lasts forever I'm
just paying attention to your eyes and
ears and I'm watching you 24/7 three six
and while so many of you talk about what
you're not going to do I make bets on
what you're going to do how many people
here thought or said in the last three
years that they were not going to ever
be on snapchat snapchat was stupid was
for kids sexting raise your hands raise
them high all those people how many of
you are now on snapchat that's what I do
for a living all right this question is
from Erin all right talking about
snapchat what are your thoughts on the
memories featured love it does it add to
I mean does it take away or add sort in
the moment guys it's gonna be the same
game forever all of these things start
as a mish Facebook's of college social
network snapchat is disappearing content
musically is dubbing you know music
songs and things that nature then they
hit scale and then they give you every
feature because they go from being a
niche app to being a content platform
got it rinse and repeat rinse and repeat
and nine years I'll get so much credit
for being right about shmoo --ga but all
I did was deployed that thesis meanwhile
everyone's like this is what now ruined
snapchat the memories feature you know
just like newsfeed ruined Facebook great
for Facebook shitty for that person
that's wrong on the record and you can
google it and see that they were [ __ ]
wrong
are you serious Aaron I hear you're a
businessman we like to hear you say that
we know you are a businessman but you
are equally motivated in my opinion you
know not only by the game earning
hustling but also by being right talk
about this damn it yeah I and honestly
I'm not proud of it I actually think
it's quite vain and not super I don't
think it's a good trait but boy am i
driven by saying I told you so
um and it's you know it's just a truth
I'm not proud I'm really truly not proud
of it actually don't think it's a very
attractive characteristic but I get off
on it I do I love I love being
underestimated I loved I hated Tiger
Woods then America hated him then I
loved him right like I loved underdogs
I'm an underdog I love underdogs I like
I loved when I Scott into vaynermedia
and adweek wrote Twitter boy is coming
to the agency world let's see how that
works out I'll tell you ad week how
worked out I [ __ ] destroyed everybody
you know and so and so you know a very
funny thing happened in the liquor
business when I got involved in my dad's
business a bunch of sons had come into
the businesses of a lot of other liquor
store owners about five years earlier
than me and they they didn't win they
weren't good and so when I came there's
a lot of people I go here's another one
right my dad was part of a group of like
ten or eleven guys or gals that had good
stores in New Jersey and like I loved
being underestimated I loved when all
those people told me to open a second
liquor store instead of this fad
internet thing that I'm doing right I
love that I live for that as a matter
fact the reason it's happening why do
you think open Vayner sports
I don't think CIA and rock nation are
worried about me right now but they will
be think about like Drew Rosenhaus
sitting there I'm gonna kill I'm gonna
kilometer I'm gonna I'm gonna kill drew
now now you have to understand something
if Drew's good enough this is how I
think about life I want to build the
biggest building in town got it I want
to build the biggest building in town so
when I say I'm gonna kill drew I don't
mean I want to kill him I mean I want to
win I want to
biggest building in town however the
reason I think that I'm likable in
business circles of people that really
know me is here's my thesis on building
the biggest building in town by going
out and building the biggest building in
town if you look very careful a lot of
other business people their theory on
building the biggest building in town is
by tearing down all the other buildings
around them if you understand that
little story you'll understand me
completely and you'll understand my
belief of what a purebred entrepreneur
is I want everybody when I want to use
business to get ten times bigger I want
all of you to build bigger businesses
than me but I want to build a bigger
business than you and what I love about
America is for all our shortcomings this
is still the best playing field to let
meritocracy rule and I love that and I
love that feeling
and when my homie Travis from uber and
when my homie Chris Sacca becomes the
best VC and goes on Shark Tank and they
beat me I'm the most pumped for them
they deserve it and then I say but it's
not over yet and that's who I am
this question comes from Tardos BBVA
Compass where does the session need to
go in next can we do this and firming it
can we do this here once and for all
there's no social media it is a slang
term for the internet tell me what
social media is people called Pokemon go
social me like there's no social media
Robert Robert we called it web 2.0
Robert wrote blog post so did I that
said web 2.0 site Facebook looks really
good like there is no social media it is
a slang term to make it easy to it for
us to refer to certain things but I
don't know like where is it going it's
the internet and the Internet's going in
a lot of places and a lot of things are
happening but will we want to always
stay in touch with each other at scale
and communicate with each other and
produce content the answer is yes and
whether that goes from the internet and
then goes into a vr environment or
something we can't think of today the
answer is yes we like to communicate
with each other we draw pictures in the
side of a cave we stood on mountains and
made smoke signals we communicate it's
what we do it's never going away I love
it it's just the term or it's just a
term this course is from Jennifer
shilling president
yes a very self-aware person yes with
thick skin how do you determine what to
react to and what people are comments
that you you know you actually take to
heart versus bloggers that's a really
interesting question the truth is I
think it's complete serendipity and
randomness you know sometimes the day of
the week the moment for example I'm
quite testy after New York Jets losses
so if I think about my scrum ups
unsocial a lot of them happen on Sunday
night you know so you know it's random
here's what I would say I think most
people are unbelievably awesome I'm I'm
the most bullish person on human beings
again and it's becoming more of an
intense feeling because we're living
through a tough time in the US where I
think we have to look at ourselves
really long and hard and we've got real
issues and I believe in those issues I
do believe they're issues however I
think we have to take it at a macro
level it is stunning that we are still
here guys we reinvented bombs that wiped
us completely out we invented bombs that
wipe us completely out a long time ago a
half a century ago what's that right
right so like the fact that we're here
like we are I'm a big fan of that human
beings are the number one underrated
thing in the world we're going to spend
all our time talking about the small
percentage that creates terrible things
like that happen in France and you know
a Dallas and the individual cops that do
these bad things and what why and they
populate as our main stories but I'm
bullish on human beings and so the wit
the things that I react to are the
following there's a lot of people that
say things about me because I put myself
out there most of them I have a lot of
empathy to why they think that they
didn't like it my ego in that moment
they didn't like something I said they
didn't like the confrontational aspect
of my East Coast Jersey thing and I
think they're right so it's very easy
when somebody takes a shot at me for me
to understand where they're coming from
the only things that I that I sometimes
engage with is when I think the intent
was really mean like bad like evil
I think 99.999% of
things that are said about me that I
don't like come from a good place it's
that person's point of view on me and
I'm very empathetic I think once in a
while somebody comes along and is just
genuinely dark in the core and I want to
fight that with some light in return and
usually I start with understanding some
people just really you know I don't know
and so it's actually very easy for me
you know you talk you IQ is decreased in
value because of technology but EQ is
greater than ever you know emotional
intelligence really really matters and I
look for that and anybody that I
surround myself with do you actually
have empathy and gratitude and
self-awareness and care and all these
warm and fuzzy things that I think are
the essential infrastructure to be
successful in business are you one of
you really big fans of humanity as well
yeah you know I just I'm gonna struggle
to the day I die of allowing yourself to
look at glass half-empty I just feel
like I feel like now I understand it's
DNA and it's wiring and you know if you
grow up with a mother who's extremely
negative it's a really tough situation
to break out of it just proven I've
understood you grew up in a tough town I
get it there's a couple of issues with
that number one nobody cares that's the
big punchline like everybody's got stuff
the problem is nobody cares and once you
understand that nobody cares and you're
complaining to empty air do you start
going in a little bit of a different
direction and yeah I mean I try to I
like putting out positivity I like that
I love that my trainer Mike who spent
the last two years with me is going
through like some weird depression thing
right now cuz he's not around me 24/7
and he's like I miss the positivity like
that's a good thing and I and I want
other people to have that and I want
other people you know what guys I want
to say something right now getting a
little bit on a bigger plane what's
happening right now in tax and business
xiety is the small minority of people
that are mad and angry and hateful and
dark are much louder than the big
percentage of us that are happy and
excited and feel great and because the
way technology works they are much
louder than they've ever been before and
so I feel like as somebody who's got
full of bright light and happiness that
I need to start getting louder about
that as well because that's the only way
we're going to come back
and you know what that right there in
real time is what it's all about because
if that's the thing that's going to get
the cloud as clap so far from this
conversation that's what we need to be
focusing on like we you know and this is
something I'm focusing inside of
vaynermedia and this is something I'm
focusing with all my friends and this is
something that I want to bring to this
network in and listen let me be really
blunt with you over the last five years
until about 18 months ago when I came
back out with a lot of content for three
years I was fairly quiet for me if
anybody's been following me since 2006
it's because I didn't want to be a
motivational speaker you know I didn't
like the part that made people rah-rah
because I was so proud that I can
actually build businesses and I think
the thing that a lot of people look at
when they see a motivational speaker is
there's fluff behind it a lot of times
there's bad behind it and I wanted to
disassociate myself from that world but
I feel more responsibility than ever as
somebody who is happy and wants other
people to be happy genuinely to get
louder and so it's an interesting time
in our country's history and and just in
human society and so if you leave with
anything I'll give you tactics on social
you'll remember scovilles amazing VR
thing if you leave with anything for any
of us please please take on the sense of
responsibility that if you've got good
and you feel good to start sharing that
content as well because the world needs
more of it
people that have fallen for a good while
have definitely noticed a change in your
tone and more you know ever towards
being positive yeah putting out content
that encourages people to be positive do
you ever do you ever get down what gets
you down I uh as long as the eight to
twelve core people in my life are
healthy I struggle to really get down I
just don't know how to do it like like
what am I like here's the game I play
I'm on the cover of Time magazine and it
says he did it right and it's me holding
a Jets Jersey right and then I get a
phone call and it's my sister usually I
don't know why telling me that my mom
died and I'm crushed
and I'm so in tune with my feelings that
I generally like can get into like
teared up devastation mode like my brain
is by the way I think the brain is so
underrated we don't know a lot about it
there's some seven years ago I decided
never to get sick again and I haven't
been sick
just a random fun fact um so the feeling
even right now telling you this story
and not even fully doing it I don't feel
good like I feel like nas right so why
would I live my life any other way why
in the world would I live my life
allowing my business wins and losses to
really impact me anywhere close to the
health and well-being and happiness of
the people that I love the most
I'm just not capable I lose business
everyday I win business every day people
say I'm the best people say I'm full of
[ __ ]
all of it happens all of it happens but
at the end of the day the the rewards
that I'm getting and I'm getting plenty
of them the rewards that I'm getting in
life are just massively secondary to
those people and that's how I live my
life and so when you live your life that
way losing a big account or somebody
calling you out is just not that painful
you just put it into context I usually
just like you know like take it you know
like you know what me this is so
interesting I think you find this
interesting
my favorite scene in movies is always
when somebody gets punched in the mouth
and they take the punch they spit their
tooth out and then they look back at the
other
person I don't have you've seen that
there's always some version of that
scene that's who I am as a [ __ ] human
being like I'm built to get punched in
the mouth I'm gonna spit my friend mm
I'm gonna look right back at you and be
like now what [ __ ]
that's how I feel got my foot and that's
it
we got questions let's get rid of
audience participation awesome let's do
it you guys ready his burger to it Scott
and then this guy over here
I post on these sexual abuse and that I
had discussion with my mouth agape
section please anonymity combined
conversation officials and it's a highly
worried thing how many people to help
other people with by being in China but
that girl is the strongest I've ever had
Jason yeah I think you were I think you
and I are just doing it right now
like the courage for a man to say it was
sexually abused in our society today is
extreme and I applaud you and and you
know these are the things I try to talk
about - I made a video Robert about who
are you worried about letting down it
was one of the big insights I figured
out on the road I'm like huh people
aren't taking chances not because
they're scared but they're scared what
their mom's gonna think they're scared
what their wife's gonna think they're
scared what their husband's gonna think
if they fail when they fail and I made
that video is me talking to somebody in
London and I mean thousands of
interactions I think we I think the
truth is the game you know the truth is
live-streaming isn't ruining America
America doing the wrong things hurts
America and I'm thrilled I'm excited
about living over the
next 10 years in society where we as a
society in America are going to take one
this is here me i'll now a step
backwards because it's time for us to
deal with our issues we're going to take
a step backwards because of facebook
live we're going to take a step
backwards but we're going to take two
steps forward because the truth is
always better and so I think the what we
do Robert is we continue to tell stories
of truth we continue to our true stories
give other people courage and it's a
momentum game you were able to do that
that helped that one individual do that
and that's why and that's why I'm
spending a lot of time you know I've
been I've been spending a lot of time in
in inner cities I did a pod I did a
morning show called The Breakfast Club a
couple months ago that went extremely
viral and you know and even looking
around seeing you know minorities
shaking their head like it went viral
right and what the interesting thing is
a lot of people don't know about me is I
went to college with a 90%
african-american college right and so I
spent a lot of time in that ecosystem
that are who my best friends are I have
a lot of empathy but still I'm not black
right when I went on that show and this
is and this is before the flare up
that's happening now I wasn't talking
about racial issues I just said nobody
cares and it was insane what's happened
in my inbox soon the same thing I just
did for everybody here said nobody cares
nobody cares
everybody's got shortcomings and one of
the things I've told so many of my
friends like that like I always tell my
friends you're right
like I tell all my female entrepreneurs
all the time you're right there's
there's a male pressure right you're
right it is harder for a female
entrepreneur to get funding from VCS it
is harder for it is harder it is harder
for a miner it is that's true but I
always ask them now what and so I think
that we just have to have more real
conversations instead of just pandering
you know I did a conference where
somebody asked me about it was a female
entrepreneur conference I've done a lot
of investing in that demo and they said
Gary is there a difference between men
and women and I said yes and people got
upset I was like what the [ __ ] is a
matter with you
there is a difference between men and
women like like you know and so like I
just think that were in a very funny
time look I think empires fall you know
I think empires fall cuz all of them
have fallen and they fall after too many
years of good just want to give you a
news alert if you're under 40
you've been real privileged your grandpa
you know like I my most viral Instagram
post ever happened the other day I think
it said something like your grandparents
you know you're complaining enough about
not getting a bunch of likes while your
grandparents went to war right like
we've just gotten soft like as a
collective you may not be soft I
definitely don't think I'm soft but you
know as a collective and even I you know
what I don't think I'm soft it's a lot
easier to work 19 hours a day then live
in the Great Depression it's a lot
easier to work 19 hours a day then be
drafted and going to Europe like what
the [ __ ] is a matter with us like it's
time for us to reconcile that we've had
two generations everyone's like oh this
generation there's it's so too bad like
they're gonna be the first generation
that is not going to have a better life
than their parents we deserve it we got
soft like you know the data is pretty
clear there's a lot more 13 and 14 year
olds that didn't work in this last
generation than the generation before it
maybe they're too soft because they're
you know they went to camp every [ __ ]
summer
like like maybe you're not maybe you're
not winning because your biggest issues
growing up was you didn't get the nude
shoe ordens like like what's the matter
with people so anyway I don't remember
what the [ __ ] I was talking about but
let's go do [ __ ]
yeah truths Robert truths your truth
help that man you know what I mean I
think it's more it helps female
entrepreneurs and minorities more to say
yes there's a difference now what that's
a truth I wish it wasn't the case but I
only play in the market that I live in
you know you're perceptive that I think
the best way to keep me he likes being
ice cream and the best way I think it's
best so real quick real quick
that's your DNA I can tell you that is
not how my dad rolls and my dad's his
best when he does what's his best for
him so I think that's idealistic alee
exactly right and you're looking at a
guy who's so thankful that that's how
he's wired but not everybody's wider
that way and that self-awareness matters
and it's important by doing it you know
like I feel very comfortable making
money and being successful as
comfortable as I am being there
emotionally for others and doing other
things by doing both
it's just actions I don't nobody should
beat themselves up for trying to do good
for themselves that's insanity right and
so I'm just comfortable on Tuesday I'm
just rolling selling stuff and making it
happen and winning Yeah right
you know dj khaled all I do is win win
with like winning right and then on
Thursday I go and speak to kids or give
back or donate a bunch of money to
somebody I don't know like everything is
different but I'm not in the business of
critiquing myself like here's the
problem I'm an
everybody is trying to project to the
world APR 8
and everything has a funny way of
figuring itself out
Robert was an absolute mainstay in the
world that I wanted to jump in in 2006 I
wanted to be part of the web 2.0 right I
was I was in left field like they were
all in San Francisco all from tech TV
and blogging I had a liquor store in New
Jersey I I what I did was I put my head
down and I worked right I just worked I
like did smart things I used the product
better I gave back to my kid and it was
chipping away chipping away chipping
away chipping away that's that's what it
is and so how do i how do i reconcile
that by doing both like sometimes I'm
selfish and sometimes I'm not
and sometimes I'm selfish for a month
and sometimes I'm not for a year you
just roll but you don't I don't over
micro analyze that like I know what's in
my heart and and then I know that if I
can Mac if you know the biggest thing I
fear is that I can't match in my actions
the intent in my heart I battle for that
because if I can pull that off I'm good
all time good you know this dude here by
the way also and they had he did I
is it the early bird that gets the worm
or is it the bird that match the sleep
patterns of the bar
both you know there's so many ways to
win right like they're so you know look
there's people that have made the NBA
that work their face off but had a
little less talent and then there's you
know guys that just had so much goddamn
talent that yeah they work but like
there's just so many different ways to
do it
the key is witchburn knew themselves
best got it that's the bird the bird
that's like [ __ ] it my wings are short
but I'll wake up earlier you know that
was good this is yd rocks around when
this random [ __ ] comes up man yeah
that's a really good question doesn't I
did something really smart three years
ago I promised myself that I wouldn't
talk about [ __ ] that I don't understand
you know as I started going to
conferences and hearing people talk
about social media and I was like
they're wrong they're wrong and they're
experts that are supposed to be experts
I don't know is the real answer to your
question I mean that I have no goddamn
idea because I don't understand city
politics tax there's a lot of other
things going on that don't allow me to
answer your question as much as I'd like
to
so the real answer boy this hurts me is
I don't know that being said I care
about this issue personally that's why I
went on The Breakfast Club I care about
this and I run content against
minorities because I want to inspire
them to understand it's not going to be
the town in the government that's going
to do it like you like the second you
understand nobody's going to do it for
you and you go and do it and then you
then listen here's what I promised about
money let me make you one promise about
money money never cares what the person
looks like that's making them money
do you understand they don't care they
just want the money and so you know I
think the way
we get female leadership minority
leadership Latino leaders all that is
just having more wins it's the same
answer I gave you about this town how
does this town win have a winner how do
you get more diversity you have more
people win right how do we get more
diversity in the NBA I don't know like
the white kids got to be good like I
don't know like like so so so the mark
the one thing there's a lot of things in
America companies politics school
organizations a lot of them that will
not allow the white kid to be an MBA or
the black kid to be the VC but business
is different the internet did it for you
right the internet did it for me man
everybody thought it was a loser I got
these and F's I was a loser immigrant
loser but then the market allowed me to
do me and now I'm a [ __ ] hero
right so so you know we're all going
with different natural talents and
different things but I think the answer
is predicated on doing it you know and
that's why I said crap I don't know how
to fix the generation of all these towns
there's a lot of that going on this
happened in Brooklyn you know like my
you know I'm like I don't know that
that's a little bit in a different plane
and I I just don't know but I know if I
can get seven kids to build big
businesses that if they are then
examples for other kids that can look
and be like I look like that and I can
do that that's how you have to do it
that's what I'm trying to do my little
contribution to that community in those
communities and by the way there's a lot
of poor white and there's all sorts of
stuff to me it's actually more of a
financial and opportunity thing you know
one of the big things back to the
breakfast club this has been you talk
about your story mine's less noble than
yours I talked about how I Bay was an
unbelievable opportunity for somebody
with no money right like go to the
dollar store go garage saling buy stuff
sell it on eBay I've gotten thousands in
the last two months of emails and d-roc
shaking his head because he sees them
just ungodly and you go to Twitter and
search my name go search my name Gary
Vee and eBay because I want you to see
it's crazy people literally tweeting
things like you know I make $200 a week
this is not very like really needing
money and I need 400 bucks this weekend
selling on eBay like unbelievable stuff
so I think it's just
I'm a motivator and I can some reason
get people to do stuff and like people
that are not hungry or not as hungry
like all shapes and sizes go and do and
so I don't know how to answer your
question for this but here's what I can
tell you if you build the best company
this town Silicon Valley New York City
they'll take you this I've watched your
it's journey
yes eleven years I got a I got a soon
but I would love to hear your lab rate
of that eighteen hours of hard work
before are not as productive it's
eighteen hours of hard work now because
of your finished earning so much it
explain that it's true and then they
talk about emergence or about how
important is a culture of wellness in
their business it's not true
I you're asking a question like us this
guy seems like such a good guy this is
gonna suck you know I I will tell you
that my energy level is exactly the same
but that's because I think I was just I
think I lit like my big believing I
should probably do this to be able to
answer this once and for all I think I
have some weird chemical imbalance with
adrenaline right like I'm just Oh like
it's just easy for me I really generally
don't feel it now let's keep going
that's right now do I think it's been
smart that I've lost 40 pounds of fat
and gained 15 pounds of muscle in the
last 24 months yes I think I think the
math of that is going to work itself out
right so I think you know later down the
line I think it's going to be beneficial
for me the other thing my friend so look
you don't need me to anoint to this
audience if you are not common sense
enough to understand physical health is
a good idea then you've already lost
let's just start with that number two
the thing that I'm actually very
passionate about in parallel and the
space that I'm going to be betting on
very heavily financially and culturally
is mental health
so I'm obsessed with meditation I think
meditation is going to be a huge play in
the consumer behavior that we're going
to have a lot more conversations about
the brain over the next 20 and 30 years
and I'm excited to really work on being
both physically and mentally the most
healthy I can because I think they work
more hand-in-hand than I think people
realize but you know to finish off your
question of course I would recommend
everybody to take care of themselves
better I'll give you one that is real I
like the feeling of grabbing my suitcase
off the top of an airplane because I'm
on them every day and like it feels
lighter and my back doesn't hurt I feel
it feels fun to pick up Xander and walk
eight blocks in New York City with him
here and his little face next to mine
because I can actually hold them whereas
before I can only go a block so there's
a lot of I would tell you that one walk
that I'm referencing carried in for 11
blocks and I got to kiss his face 40
times was worth every second that I put
into health
yes but man I love you when in this
situation right now yeah interesting
question so Lina this is very nerdy this
is probably interesting for four of you
I'll try to go fast so you know if your
ass big of a Jets fan as I am the Jets
are in trouble because they don't have a
lot of young talent right like they've
they've invested all on the defensive
line
you know they I just saw text as I was
getting on here that I think Moe
Wilkerson just got a big contract which
Moe is literally probably my favorite
jet and I'm against that signing because
I don't think you paid that kind of
money for defensive linemen and today's
NFL I would pay fits as the Jets owner
for the next two years because they're
enough they'd have to they have some
chance of a miracle Super Bowl run if
there's a lot of injuries with Brandon
Marshall with Revis with Decker they're
top-heavy with older guys so here's what
I would say to you I would sign fits to
a two-year deal and pay him 12 14 fine
his agent is asking for that range fine
or and I'd have to really there's a
couple things I don't know about how
healthy are my old guys this and that
like it's probably a couple things I
don't have it's data point on there's
only one thing there's only two moves
for them either sign fits for two years
and try to hope to hell there's enough
injuries that lets you sneak in because
the talent is tier two not to your one
to win or blow the whole thing [ __ ]
up you know what I probably do and is
trade Revis and marsh and the problem
with the NFL is what a salary cap you
don't get anything for these guys like
what am I going to get for Revis or
Marshall or Deckard you're gonna get for
v six ramp it's crazy real talent but
the way the cap is the money against the
cap is too valuable so they're in a rock
and a hard place
hey man how are you
it is easy thank you brother so what's
your take on something I saw a video
that did a couple weeks ago kind of
spontaneously stocky tumor and I
literally when I saw the video I came
out of a chair like this thank you for
finding it run fools that's there to be
that but the reason it stood out to me
is a quick background and yeah so I love
to bring forward 1988 with architecture
school and sub layer behind it yes and
same thing happen to me
same thing happened to me so that yeah
real quick just to get everybody aligned
somebody rolled up on me we're leaving a
conference luckily having d-roc around
we capture these moments she came up to
me like I rolled down my window she's
like can you just in my selfie video
with me can you just say three words
that would motivate me forever or some
like that and I said you're gonna die
I mean I am you know again similar to
that bird thing I just said like I don't
know where a cut like that's what came
out of me but it motivates me every day
I think it you know it's funny I think I
really hit that one for me like that's
what motivates me which is that's true
and so like why wouldn't you live like
like you only have one life so good
where I was optimistic in the way you
were cuz mines the same I was in dorm
room my freshman year of college in 1994
and I saw the Internet and I was like oh
my god this and I never owned a computer
and I'd been on a computer 20 hours of
my life because I was an F student and I
didn't know what the internet was I said
something like is this the information
superhighway like I don't know what was
going on and I just knew right away that
my life had changed at that moment but I
also think like there's a lot of
different things guys I have a book that
I'm writing that I'll eventually put out
called I wish everybody was an immigrant
and it's not too different than what I
just told you over there in the corner
which is you know it's in Vantage I have
an advantaged that all my grandparents
died in Russia except for one like like
everybody died in Russia and do you know
why everybody died in Russia at 50 and
55 and 60 because nobody wanted to live
do you know what communism is I mean you
know they want to live like all my
grandparents both my grandfather's went
to jail because they were Jewish because
there was post-world War to Europe like
like you know like and I don't mean jail
like locked up for the night I mean ten
years you know so like I uh I I feel
like I came out the womb knowing like I
was born in a [ __ ] place I got lucky as
hell to come to America my mom is the
greatest person on earth and she
parented me like my dad taught me not to
be full of [ __ ] and that saved me and
now I mean I think that moments been in
my heart from the get to be honest with
you I think we got time for one more
how about that lady all the way then
let's go with her that's what you yep
you I like I turned around
who me what's your name yeah turn that's
awesome thank you my favorite episode of
Wine Library TV Oh God so this is a good
opportunity to reminisce about something
that's so near dear my heart I don't
think about Wine Library TV that often
these days so I thank you Terrence
it's funny how like not as serious as
everything else but you just brought me
a lot of happiness
I loved the episode when I did it
outside in the snow because that was a
fun episode to get a little nerdy for
you Scoble and the others that was my
first episode to make the front page of
Digg calm and if you guys remember that
was such a big deal for the Internet if
you get on Digg that was like that
grandma I love the episode I had with
Jim Cramer from Mad Money because
everybody was calling me the Jim Cramer
of wine I thought that was a funny meme
Ajay's first episode when he turned 21
that's something you know the fact that
me and my brother in 40 years can sit
down and with all our grandkids put on a
screen or wherever we live in those days
and show them an episode of AJ turning
21 super cool the episodes with my dad
you know were super fun to me you know
just like again similar stuff when he's
gone I can go have that content I you
know what my favorite episode was that
the episode where I ate all those
different foods that was the first
episode to go really viral I ate like
dirt and like cereal and cherries that
episode caught the attention of Conan
O'Brien's producers and then I did Conan
and you have to remember to scold right
this was 2007 that's right socks turd i
conan o'brien's producers emailed me and
said we'd like you to do the corner by
show now this is 2007 most people don't
even know what youtube is yet right I I
looked very careful at the email address
because I thought it was my friends
playing a joke on me
I emailed them back I like held my
breath it was real this is how
tight-knit the entire internet community
was in 2007 I announced that I'm going
to be on Conan the whole internet had my
back
you know Gruber from daring fireball
boeing-boeing dig read it like everybody
all of the few people that were on
Twitter at that point every like I felt
well you know what I don't know if I've
ever felt more professional pressure
than being in the green room looking at
Twitter this is again 2007 early and
just seeing basically the entire web 2.0
and remember I reference it earlier
tonight I was a newcomer to it I was
like this kind of different thing and
they all rallied behind me like the
iJustine and they Frank and these early
video bloggers they all were like you
did it for us like teeth like you're
gonna be on a video blogger on the Conan
show and I was sitting there I was like
I have to and I've never been on TV so
like Here I am like never been on TV and
I'm going on this big stage and when I
found out later is that Conan doesn't I
didn't know this Conan I didn't know
there was anybody who did a different
Conan doesn't rehearse when I wanted to
do the Today Show and dr. oz and Ellen
DeGeneres all that they were Hearst
Conan's improv so luckily I ended up
being improv but I didn't know that
about myself literally I'm just like
sitting there in the behind this curtain
just like this and they're like you're
about to go out in three two and I'm
saying [ __ ] I have to deliver big for
the whole web 2.0 video blogging
community not just for me I get pushed
out I don't know if any of you've seen
it it crushed I got Conan to eat dirt
he's unbelievable I probably got paid
the best compliment Oliver get paid
which was it ends the crowd goes crazy
Conan turns to me I didn't realize how
notoriously tough Conan was on his
guests these are things I learned later
in life he looks at me goes that was
phenomenal he goes so where do you
perform and I go what he goes where do
you do your your act and I was like oh
I'm not a comedian I'm a wine guy goes
get the [ __ ] out of here
and so and so I would say this cereal I
think was like 148 maybe the cereal the
dirt the cigar because that became the
blueprint for the Today Show Ellen
DeGeneres Conan which no question gave
me even more street cred in the web
community which led to a very big change
in my life
Thank You Birmingham thank you so much I
love you guys thank you
you see the lobby